my name is Richard collenberg I'm the
editor of the website TV smarts com and
Peter mentioned that I was the founding
archivist of the American Film Institute
that was a long time ago since then I've
been involved in journalism and media
and discovered in the course of that a
wealth of resources that allow me to
contribute to the effort that all of you
are working in which is to foster a cult
of a culture maybe a cult of use of this
material that we've been discussing I
think the emphasis today and yesterday
has been on staff post secondary my hope
and my activities is been to engage the
secondary school arena in this process
of using these audio-visual materials
and specifically that the students would
use it I think we've said enough and
perhaps not enough about the problem of
the generations and I find that working
with students moves the culture of use
farther and faster and working with the
teachers the TV smarts website is one of
several that uses the following material
to generate a media menu each week we go
through the standards of various states
i have here the one just one page that
shows the physical layout of the
standards that the state of california
and then the i have some examples what
we're doing here is developing a way of
by hand rather than by technology going
into the that's we want to go
back going into the words used to
describe the standards just arbitrarily
I'll use it since we're in New York I'll
go to a new york one these words sorted
by hand also appear in the descriptors
of television broadcasts that are put on
line each week by the commercial
networks and cable casters are about to
undergo glue and what I've been doing by
hand is seeing where there's a match
between the words in the descriptors and
when there is a match we put that in
they weave we vet these things let's see
oh it's word here's an example of one of
the
it's too small to read but it's about
the forces of nature and it's about
geology these words turned out to be
available in the eighth grade and the
12th grade and even the 4th grade
learning standards as posted on the web
and they match up with these things that
we found on this website of this
particular broadcaster I'll have I have
another example here we're talking about
programs that were made by the
commercial broadcasters for broadcast to
the general audience where we have PBS
in there because they also broadcast to
the general audience but the point I'm
making is that we're not talking about
kid vid here we're talking about
programs that were made for the general
audience and who are making available an
informational site that tells the
students or the teachers or the parents
in advance when a program is going to be
on TV thats related to what they might
be studying in school here's an example
of the particular at least one version
of the site let's see if I can scroll
down here
TV smarts is a site that is imported
into the websites of various schools and
educational web sites around the country
is you can see that we sort by
elementary middle and high school
appropriateness okay whether it was in
the standards here's a description in
the middle of the the topic and the
source which is the channel and the
broadcast down at the bottom let me see
if I can get this we have a little
information box which lists the website
which frequently accompanies a broadcast
very recently this website has also been
the source of information on how to log
on to the streaming video of the very
show Patricia gave me a phrase that I
cherish as to what all of this amounts
to and this is the new bookshelf in the
library this is the time that somebody
finds out that this material is
available and because of the onrush of
culture I mean of Technology turns out
that a lot of these things become
streaming so this is the opening weekend
of this this material now what's going
on with it well the short answer is that
when students are told by a teacher to
watch these shows at home they do and
that enlivens the school discussion
that's the good news when students write
essays based on this material they write
longer essays than they would if they
had been in sent to the library to write
a book so the teachers are burdened with
additional text to have to wade through
in a demonstration site in Los Angeles
at a place with the rather dramatic
title of Hollywood High School which is
simply the name of the district of town
where the school is it's not really
connected to the movie
one teacher has an interesting policy of
no paper she assigns the students to do
their research for papers I mean for
assignments and SH online and did she
said you either email me the result or
hand me a disk and so she has to wade
through all of the outcome on her
computer but point is the students are
exposed to material which is broader
than what's going on in the other
classrooms in this very school and this
results in a tent pole effect where they
score higher on the standardized tests
and in that particular high school that
classroom alone was able to produce
results which move the average results
for the school up to a point where they
were able to sustain their accreditation
the students like this one after one
particular test the teacher told me that
the kids came in and sort of grabbed her
by the shoulder and said we knew what
was on the test the point is that they
had seen things on television that
accumulate over the period of the year
that might not be that week's material
but the point is they knew it when they
were going into the test and were able
to draw on this I learned that that is a
phenomenon for my son who is actually a
biologist although he's about to
graduate as an architect but he learns
all kinds of things by watching
television and one day he did something
while he was in an undergraduate
situation he was bored and so he took
the LSAT because his college roommate
was doing it and he scored well enough
to get into UCLA but he's neither an
attorney nor wanting to be an attorney
he's a biologist and an architect but I
asked him where'd you get the
information the answer is from the kind
of stuff that you sir are putting up on
well I I think that what the British
university film & Television Council is
doing is something that I simply want to
have a role in bringing to the United
States by the way I want to make a
parenthetical reference here to two
things one google and the other v-chip
and then i'll shut up google when you go
on say for instance last week they were
running a history channel series on the
Inquisition a very lengthy and pretty
detailed account of that phenomenon and
if you googled the Inquisition there was
no reference to that particular program
being available we don't have a info box
where a student can go on and simply
arbitrarily I mean not arbitrarily but
according to their need type in the
topic that an essay has been assigned by
the teacher or that they're just
generally interested in in and then find
what's going to be on TV in the upcoming
fortnight it just doesn't exist the site
that we have called TV smarts was
started by myself and a Canadian
engineer whose contribution to Western
civilization was the v-chip which is
built into the American and Canadian
television shows sets by mandate it now
is used to sort three things which I
call Warren slashing and well anyway sex
and violence and bad language but there
are 23 other letters in the alphabet
that it could sort for it's not widely
known that the v-chip can be used to
select for a program or against a
program and when he goes down to talk to
the FCC even they say well what is there
that you would like to select for and he
uses the column each week to answer the
question of what's
potentially valuable on TV that the
students might profit from or a parent
might want their kids to see the other
use that's being made of this is
libraries oddly enough not so much
teachers but library's print out this
column and put it by the cash register
because they have a knowledge of that if
something's on TV it drives circulation
and they literally are able to take a
book that maybe nobody has read for
years I'll just arbitrarily say that we
will talk about grapes of wrath if
there's a broadcast on the Turner
channel of the John Ford movie and we
have a little notice that it's coming
librarians like to know about this in
advance so they can go into the
storeroom and pull all the old copies of
grapes of wrath because there will be a
demand for that book because it's been
on television word gets out I hope that
some people in the group here will feel
as I do about the British will feel
about this is this idea of posting
information where students can look
through the standards or somehow vetted
information about upcoming broadcasts
and bring it to a school near you we're
doing that in a strange way in Los
Angeles by having students learn how to
do this sorting by themselves and making
up their own personal media menus the
there's a list if anybody is interested
I just email me at TV smarts com and
there's a place about us with an email
and our address but the students are
equipped with this list come on
okay this is from the cable industry but
these are the they're about 50 of these
live sites where the students can go
sorting through and depending on the
subject that they're studying they can
find appropriate programming and there
is a in addition by the way to the
posting on the TV smarts and the
Hollywood High School thing it goes on
to a site called whyville net which is
actually for middle schoolers I
mentioned that at the end by virtue of
my theory that the programs were made
for adults to view but they have a
dramatic thrust to them that makes it
accessible to kids as young as 6 and the
point I'm trying to make is that there
is no really inappropriate time for
really fine video to be exposed to a kid
whether it be a John Ford movie or a
documentary from Nova their sponges and
they pick up this stuff and they can
deploy it as they take tests through
their career tattoos things in their
mind that they drawn and I recommend
that anybody who wants to take up this
idea and do it instead of me or with me
or without me see if they can find some
way of sorting through the listings that
the broadcaster's put up and the
standards and merge them somehow for the
specific purpose of your school or your
department or even your own kids thank
you very much